cécilia de vigilance et c'est une
chanson qui est extraite de l'album
tendance qui est une chanson disait
barbelivien
c'est le dernier 5 6 ans si vous
disposiez toujours des lunettes à tout
d'un coup je non mais j'avais des supers
prof de maths ça va pas enfin ce matin
physique
oui mais vous voulez pourquoi pas sur
scène non parce que je ne porte que tu
viennes ma copine se trouvait très bien
alors l'olympia donc avec un spectacle
didier plus comment on peut dire plus
restreint que ça c'est à dire déjà il ya
moins de deux mois une machinerie parce
que la scène ne s'y prête pas bon il y
aura un décor parce qu on a recréé une
ambiance un peu différente
oui parce que c'est le danseur oui il ya
des musiciens et des le célèbre musicien
je suis vraiment ravi parce que ça
tourne bien comme on dit dans le jargon
du métier
et puis plusieurs un petit clin d'oeil
quand même au début parce que je pense
qu'on peut aller dans un endroit comme
ça sans censure oui j'ai de bons
souvenirs ici le temps comme un coût de
vos camarades alors fond des filets là
cela dit vous avez analysé ce qui
s'était passé au zénith parce que c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque le public pouvait pas
entièrement suivi c'était quoi la taille
de la seule c'était pas le même en
surplomb c'est moi je considère que pour
moi personnellement je considère cette
unité globale
ah oui ah oui parce que je veux dire
c'est un peu facile de casser du sucre
toujours sur les mêmes gens bons mois en
l'occurrence je suis la prof très facile
ça fait 25 ans que ça dure d'entre eux
croient pourquoi ça continuerait pas on
fait cela dit pour moi le zénith vont
même si on n'a pas fait le plein tous
les jours ça a été une expérience
extraordinaire
une ambiance fabuleuse et pour rien au
monde j'irais cracher dans la soupe peu
gêné donc ces messieurs s'il continue à
colporter des bruits l'a courageusement
voulons leur montrer ce que je sais
faire aussi
moi j'avance et je fais pas du tout pour
pour en revanche un nom je vais leur
montrer je fais ça parce que j'aime
chanter parce que je trouve que c'est
bien de temps en temps que quand un
rendez vous avec les gens qui vous
ennuie où vous êtes c'est à dire le
public ici qu'il a la cabane celle à qui
vous veut du man est possible même si je
peux en citer plusieurs noms me science
que et pourquoi ça démarre ça démarre
toujours sur un an on dit sur un journal
à scandale très souvent et d'ailleurs
cette histoire du zénith on ne parlait
que de celle là été démarrée par
monsieur wermus pour ne citer que nous
allons y voit le petit polo et voilà
c'est tout il va vous répondre là on
sera produire mieux s'ils vont seulement
s'il ya quelque chose pour me faire voir
qu'on n'est pas là ce n'était pas
simplement simplement moi ce que je veux
dire c'est que comme vous avez signé
selon moi je fais pas du tout la pia
pour prouver quoi que ce soit parce que
j'ai envie de chanter pour vous écrire
tout un jour pour si vous avez des
pendules à remettre à l'heure comme on
dit également
peut-être oui je commence c'était je
suis pas parti en vacances donc j'ai
commencé à griffonner moi qui étais
rason wells avec ça je veux dire que
bush qui ont dénoncé plus en rien
on verra bien de ça nous mène en tous
les cas ce sera la vérité ça c'est sûr
c'est peut-être ou peut-être pourquoi
pas faire cela dit votre votre public
celui qui vous suit puis le nouveau je
suppose n'y a là des adolescents après
tout vous en connaissez un bien est en
fait c'est un préadolescent et d'avoir 4
14 ans maintenant à huile à 14 ans elle
devait il doit vous donner des idées sur
ce qui se fait sur ce qui est ou ce qui
m'a renom ben c'est à dire qu'il ya il a
son jugement il est très creux très
nette
il aime où il aime pas ou bien intimant
pas cadeau ça je trouve ça pas de cadeau
non aucun cadeau mais bon salle éclate
quoi quand je cherchais le mot ce n'est
qu'après il faut que je sois que vous
voyez vous vous restez dans le jardin
nous on l'attendait très bien alors vous
vous rejoins le 3 octobre à l'olympia
il faut savoir que l'on vous retrouve
demain sur antenne 2 et bien d'en
changer